not only is he risen he's gone as say
mark tells the Easter story Jesus is up
and he is out he's not hanging around
the graveyard to meet the morning women
but art agon already on the way to
Galilee where he awaits Peter and the
rest certainly among the Easter stories
st. John's Easter is more touching with
Mary finally recognizing the teacher in
the garden and st. Matthews is more
cinematic with its earthquakes and
stunned soldiers but st. mark i think is
the most consistent and the most real
all through mark story jesus seems to be
ten steps ahead of everybody else in
understanding everyone else is lagging
behind not just the pharisees but also
the disciples they misunderstand and
they misinterpret him they are confused
by his predictions and finally when
things get serious they run away just as
Jesus predicted and now on Easter
morning the women come to the tomb with
their burial supplies not even sure how
they're going to get in but Jesus is
long gone ever since authoritative early
manuscripts of Mark's Gospel were found
in the last century which left off the
two familiar endings of Mark the endings
that fit what we expect the usual
post-resurrection appearances and the
commands of Jesus the ending of Mark's
Gospel has made people uncomfortable
it's left them dangling listen to how
not just this story but the whole gospel
of mark ends so the women went out and
they fled from the tomb for terror and
amazement had seized them and they said
nothing to anyone for they were afraid
it ends with a preposition
dot dot dot the late donald jewel wrote
about teaching this text in his seminary
that his students wrestled and wrangled
and twisted and did all sorts of
violence to this text trying to find a
way out trying to make this story fit
what they wanted which was that the
women went out and told everybody and
everybody was happy in the disciples
built the church in the rest is history
right they were trying to find a way out
but jewel wrote that he was most touched
by a young woman who finally spoke up
and said that she had read the ending of
Mark by herself the night before and
said I cried the tomb is empty but the
only response we see and Mark is fear
mark is relentlessly consistent Jesus's
disciples are not miraculously
transformed by an empty tomb into heroes
or saints any more than some of us will
be after this service even when the
promised resurrection comes they run
away in terror they have failed Jesus at
every step along the way and even now
when everything he predicted has come
true they are stunned and frightened
they are not ready the routes a mark
story Jesus has told the disciples not
to tell anyone about him who he is or
the miracles he performs and now finally
at the end of the story the young man in
white in the tomb says go and tell
finally go and tell and what do they do
they run away and they don't tell
anybody I've told many of you an old
family legend of mine that I think fits
with this feeling about Mark from San
Sabbath street in El Paso Texas where I
grew up I must have been for when this
happened because I think we moved out of
that house when I was five some of you
know my father worked for a drugstore
chain they still existed at that time
and one of the joys of being his son was
that Easter candy was dropped off in his
office by the salesman and came home to
me and my brother
the most glorious of which was every
year the giant solid chocolate Easter
rabbit for a four-year-old you can
imagine this was more pleasure than I
could handle on Saturday morning before
Easter my father arrived home from work
about noon and in his usual wonderful
soft-spoken way presented my older
brother and I with our rabbits this was
a moment to be savored literally and
emotionally we retired to our shared
bedroom and carefully unwrapped our
prizes pure brown delight with pink
icing eyes and finally when we could no
wait no longer a nibble of the long ears
and then another but something was wrong
with my rabbit it tasted funny
not at all as a chocolate rabbit should
and so with tears of disappointment
brimming in my eyes I handed it to my
older brother who also nibbled and
agreed that the bunny was not right and
so we paraded into the living room of
our little house where my mother was
playing bridge with her best friends the
annoying whiny children again you know
and with a tug on her blouse I handed
her the rabbit and said my bunny is
broken I was padded and praised and
assured that the money was fine but at
the brink of tears again I insisted and
so the chocolate rabbit was passed
around the table and each woman took a
nibble and affirmed the bunny is fine I
returned to my room with my brother who
was unusually supportive I forget about
these times sometimes i nibbled a little
more in hopes that my childhood fears
had again been solved by adult magic but
the rabbit still tasted wrong as I SAT
miserably nibbling the rabbit that I
knew was wrong that had been told by all
the proper authorities was fine my
brother rummaged in the trash and found
the boxes that the rabbits had come in I
couldn't read but he could and on the
back of my box that my rabbit had come
in there was a clear red rubber stamp
that said wax for display use only
we may at first think of st. Mark's
Easter as a wax rabbit st. Mark's Easter
doesn't taste like Easter as Thomas long
has written Easter is supposed to have
post-resurrection appearances and joyful
seaside meals with Jesus and scenes of
reconciliation and forgiveness with
Peter and Thomas garden embraces of the
risen Lord and the disciples excitedly
shouting He is risen but I think in the
end mark is solid chocolate not wax his
is an Easter like no other as
confounding and as paradoxical and
mysterious and as full as Jesus himself
in marks Easter there is no emotional
culmination no reconciliation no
reassurance to the disciples that it
will all be all right mark sends us home
from easter worship not with the sense
that the story of jesus is neatly
wrapped up for another year sending us
home inspired but perhaps unable to
recognize that idealized story in the
lives we go home to mark sends us home
to our real lives lives with daily
struggles to care for the ones we love
to figure out who we are and where we're
going and what is right to learn what it
means to do justice and love kindness
and walk humbly in a world that perverts
justice and loves violence and walks
telling god what to do mark opens a door
yes the disciples did fail every step
along the way right up to the end just
as we do but Jesus does not fail them
and that's what matters the young men in
white in the tomb says a few simple
words he says do not be alarmed you are
looking for Jesus who was crucified he
has been raised he is not here look
there is the place they laid him but go
tell his disciples and Peter that he is
going ahead of you to Galilee and there
you will see him just as he told you the
message of marks Easter is he is going
head of you whether the frightened women
tell anyone or not Jesus is already on
the way to Galilee he's not lingering in
the graveyard to reassure us but as
always he is out ahead of us fulfilling
his promises to us loose in the world
marks Easter is not a wax imitation as
long as Easter is about resolving the
story with the happy ending we desire we
can close Holy Week reassured that God
is in God's heaven and all is well with
the world but marks Jesus isn't at least
bit interested in our reassurance even
our response is not the issue Jesus does
not wait for us to get the concept he is
off to heal the broken and share the
good news of God with the poor he has
defeated death he has opened the gates
of hell however you define it he has
proven that love can defeat power and
weakness defeat strength he has showed
us that the seeds of truth we plant do
indeed grow in silence and darkness and
finally burst forth we want the sweet
Jesus that will embrace us in the garden
and dry our Good Friday tears and let us
rest but marks Jesus is God a God not of
happy feelings but of justice and
holiness and peace he is there a short
journey ahead of us waiting for us to
start the story over again as in mark 11
this is the good news of Jesus Christ
the Son of God good news for the real
world we live in the world of Trayvon
Martin and George Zimmerman the world of
Rick Santorum and Barack Obama and Mitt
Romney a world still reeling from a
financial disaster brought on by the
greed of a few a world yearning for a
moral compass as we entertain ourselves
to death st. Mark's Easter message for
us is simple in following Jesus we will
all fail his justice and truth are
bigger than our lives or our brains can
quite handle but he does not send us on
ahead with a pat on the
back in a motivational speech as he
proved to us on Good Friday he goes
ahead of us into our deepest fears our
most secret regrets into the inner
contradictions of our society and it's
comfortable in justices and he defeats
them with forgiveness and freedom he
cuts a path ahead of us a path we may
not fully understand but a path clearer
and truer than any other this world
offers again as Donald jewel writes
marks Jesus has promised and encounter
with him against which there is no
assured defense however much we want one
God will be put off neither by our
failures or infidelity or our most
sophisticated interpretive scheme that's
for you Yale folks there is reason to
hope that our defenses against him will
finally prove insufficient and that we
will no longer have the last word that's
what Mark is saying God sends his
messenger back to us to say do not be
afraid he is risen just as he promised
he is waiting for you just up ahead just
as he promised and whether we run away
in terror or whether we eventually make
our way to meet him he is ahead of us
showing the way Alleluia Christ is risen
amen